take a look at the home road splits
for the veteran right hander two and
four overall much better returns
at busch stadium this year alex than on
the road
he's a guy that's pitched there a long
time home is home for him and he's a
comfort guy he's a field guy tonight
we'll see two pitchers are throwing 89
not 98 they have really the art of
pitching
and wayne rides a guy that's honed his
craft for over 15 years the battery made
batman and robin with molina obviously
going back to 2006. one out base runner
aboard against wainwright to start the
visitors first and now it's the catcher
wilson contreras
and contreras went around on the
curveball it's 28 year old veteran
right-hander zach davies on the mound
for the cubs tonight davies has been
much better
in the second month of the season as
compared to five april starts two and
two overall with an era in the middle
fives but the returns have late have
been a lot better
as edmond hooks one into the corner
and that's a fair ball off the wall
tommy edmond
into second with a lead off double
two out two on now for harrison bader
vader sends that one out to center field
happ's got it
nothing despite a couple of the base
runners in the home first
adam wainwright leading things off in
the home third in a scoreless
start to this sunday finale
and wayne white leans into one to deep
left and caught at the track by peterson
nice swing here in an 88 miles an hour
fast but a little disconnected
didn't quite get it off but it looked
good off the bat
in a really nice play here by peterson
in the back end
here's a situation where you have two
outs two men in scoring position you
have a veteran molina who's been red hot
hit an o2 home run yesterday with the
base open
and baiter on deck be very careful here
i would not mind just putting them on
oh boy out to center field well hit
pat with room to steal it at the track
chris bryant leads off for the cubs
bryant takes a pitch for
a strike the bottom part of the zone
bryant thought it was low
i think somebody's just been run from
the game i think rossi just got tossed
and david ross has been ejected from the
game for the second time this year
making his thoughts known on
eric bakkus's strike zone tonight yeah
man we talked about things to watch in
this game as eric bakkus
the 30-year-old rookie umpire how is he
gonna you know how's he gonna do to this
first test
right and he's been a little bit
inconsistent and ross just had
enough rbi
opportunity now for justin williams one
for eight in the series first pitch to
him lined to the rover position
and horner gets it back into second in
time for the double play
what a play by nico horner
horner playing in short right field on
the ship
caught the line drive by justin williams
turned around
bader thought that was going to get down
and he was caught off second base
and then erases the lead off double two
outs
chris bryant there's a ground ball
up the line bare handed by arenado
nobody does it better folks
the cardinals dugout and it looks like
yachty and jeff albert leading the
scouting meeting
making it all make sense to adam
wainwright who's in a big situation here
against ryan tapara now let me set the
stage up for you man here you have one
of the most aggressive first basemans in
the game he's going to be charging
like it's nobody's business third
baseman will be doing the same thing
the cardinals have an option they bunt
but wayne white has the right
to pull it back and slash so this would
be a little bit of a
you know cannon golf play here let's
keep an eye on rizzo and wainwright
wainwright gets it down to para to third
and they miss the out on the lead runner
excellent job here by topera getting off
the mound
getting to this ball but had a lot more
time
looks like he got him there
oh you got to look at that one again
just winged it a little bit we'll watch
after the slide too
because for me he's out there
but if we follow the play i think he
gets him on the toe
there again there will be no review
base is loaded and nobody out
edmond puts it in play corners going to
come home
they get the out at the plate
still loaded one god for goldschmidt
popped him up
contreras has a play on it for route
number two
the next 2-2 he got him
you talk about pulling a rabbit out of a
hat
the cardinals squander a base is loaded
no out opportunity
the cardinals tap their closer reyes has
been terrific this year
here's javi baez now go ahead run it
third
baes swings and sends a drive to center
field twisting is bader and it's gone
well as we said earlier yeah he's going
to swing and miss
but he will also produce
shooters keep shooting and hitters keep
swinging
and baez first the 58-footer
and then reyes does him a favor and
repeats it but this time spin
strike a mistake tobias check this out
greg kimbrell's going to swing the bat
here here we go
three and two and he strikes out
kimbrell
nolan renato yadi molina harris and
bader in the cardinal half of the inning
3-1 pitch
and arenado swings and sends a drive
into center
half makes the catch it'll tag and score
goldschmidt
and it's 2-1 chicago justin williams
represents the last chance for the
cardinals tonight in the bottom of the
10th then he
the 2-2 from kimbrough couldn't hold off
on that one
kimbrell earns the win and the chicago
cubs a
team full of cat burglars sneak out of
here with a 2-1 victory they take two
out of three from the cardinals
and go to bed tonight trailing st louis
by just
two games atop the nl central two to one
cubs in extra
innings the final score tonight